fin a la policía de la moral en Irán así
lo anunció la fiscalía general de ese
país en declaraciones recogidas por
medios locales esta ha sido una de las
exigencias del movimiento Popular de
protesta que inició hace tres meses tras
la muerte de la joven Max a mini bajo
custodia policial y que ha dejado entre
300 y 450 muertos
Indonesia evacuó alrededor de 2000
habitantes de la isla de Java en
mediaciones del volcán elsemerú que
entró en erupción esta madrugada las
autoridades decretaron alerta máxima en
la zona en donde el año pasado un evento
similar dejó al menos 50 muertos
todo listo para la segunda fecha de
octavos de final de la Copa del Mundo en
Qatar Francia Polonia Inglaterra y
senegal se disputan este domingo dos
cupos a los cuartos de final Tenemos
reporte de nuestro enviado especial
Bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
las noticias de fin de semana en France
24 Mi nombre es Daniela blandona
comenzamos en Irán en donde el fiscal
general muham montaceri anunció el fin
de la policía de la moral esta polémica
fuerza es la encargada de vigilar la
vestimenta de las personas y detener
sobre todo a las mujeres que no se
cubren de acuerdo con los códigos
dictados por la República islámica ya
monta sería había adelantado un día
antes que se estaba analizando si se
debía o no cambiar la ley que obliga a
las mujeres a cubrirse la cabeza de ser
implementadas ambas medidas serían
consideradas una sesión ante las
multitudinarias protestas que iniciaron
hace tres meses tras la muerte de la
joven Max a mini bajo custodia de ese
órgano policial la movilización ha sido
la más grande en años con hasta 450
fallecidos y este domingo justamente sus
promotores citaron a una huelga general
de tres días a partir del lunes sin
confirmar La abolición de la policía de
la moral el presidente
dejó abierta a la puerta a lo que llamó
flexibilidad en la implementación de la
Constitución
los fundamentos islámicos y republicanos
de Irán están arraigados
constitucionalmente pero existen métodos
para implementar la Constitución que
pueden ser flexibles y como avanzábamos
en titulares el volcán semeru ubicado en
la isla Indonesia de Java entró en
erupción esta madrugada las autoridades
se elevaron el nivel de actividad A4 el
más alto de la escala de alerta Lo que
implica peligro para zonas pobladas
también fueron ordenadas evacuaciones de
unas 2000 personas en la región en la
que el año pasado la erupción del mismo
volcán dejó al menos 50 muertos y miles
de desplazados
hemos preparado escuelas y salones en
las aldeas cercanas los prepararemos
Hasta que el puesto de observación de
semeru declare que es seguro regresar a
casa cuando lo sea podemos pedirles que
regresen a casa pero si aún no es el
caso deben permanecer en nuestros
refugios cambiamos de información
mientras la invasión rusa de Ucrania
está a punto de entrar en su décimo mes
la ciudad de gersón en el sur del país
fue bombardeada el sábado en la noche
provocando una ola de incendios que
dejaron Al menos dos heridos en las
últimas semanas se ha recrudecido el
ataque en la región desde que fuerzas
ucranianas retomaron el control de su
capital lo que ha dejado a gran parte
del país sin electricidad mientras se
prepara para un largo invierno veamos el
informe
Ucrania el invierno pasado esta pequeña
ciudad al suroeste de kiev era el hogar
de unas 5000 personas ahora tras nueve
meses de guerra está en ruinas los pocos
residentes que quedan luchan por
satisfacer sus necesidades diarias
es difícil para todos quiero mi casa
quiero vivir en paz y que mi hijo y su
novia tengan un lugar donde vivir porque
ahora no tienen vida no es vida
se están construyendo rápidamente
viviendas de emergencia y será
necesarias las temperaturas invernales
en Ucrania caen a menudo hasta los 25
grados bajo cero y permanecen así
durante semanas al sur en gersón
recientemente liberada las fuerzas rusas
expulsadas siguen bombardeando la ciudad
mientras los trabajadores de
Electricidad se apresuran a reparar las
líneas eléctricas bombardeadas cuando
empezamos a reparar el bombardeo
comienza inmediatamente parece que nos
ven o que alguien les informa ha
ocurrido muchas veces reparamos las
líneas eléctricas y al día siguiente
tenemos que volver a repararlas
el invierno también ha llegado aquí los
residentes dependen de la luz de las
velas para iluminarse mientras que el
gobierno ha instalado tiendas de campaña
de emergencia a las que la gente puede
acudir para calentarse y cargar sus
teléfonos
Moscú ha respondido con semanas de
bombardeo sobre las instalaciones
civiles de Electricidad y agua luego del
éxito de la contraofensiva del ejército
ucraniano una campaña destinada a
quebrar la voluntad de la población de
seguir resistiendo y que según la ONU
puede ser un crimen de guerra
nos quedamos en Europa los miembros del
partido conservador de Francia los
republicanos eligen hoy a su próximo
líder una figura llamada enderezar el
rumbo del partido que salió debilitado
de las más recientes elecciones frente
al movimiento de Emmanuel macron y la
extrema derecha tres candidatos compiten
para reemplazar a Cristian Jacob el
favorito Es
quien ocupó el segundo lugar durante las
primarias presidenciales el año pasado y
está en el ala más a la derecha del
partido también compite Eugenio un
candidato más joven y más centrista de
ser elegido ha prometido un
relanzamiento del colectivo que incluye
cambiar su nombre y sede el tercer
nombre es uno ojetelo líder republicano
en el senado francés
y en El Salvador cerca de Diez mil
militares y policías rodearon el sábado
las calles de soyapango este municipio
ubicado en la periferia de la capital
San Salvador es el tercero más poblado
del país y considerado bastión de las
pandillas hoy es protagonista en la
guerra librada por el presidente nayib
bukele contra estos grupos
soyapango en las afueras de San Salvador
vehículos de las fuerzas de seguridad
recorren las calles mientras drones
sobrevuelan la zona miles de soldados y
policías controlan cualquier entrada o
salida del municipio el presidente nayib
bukele ha prometido una guerra sin
cuartel contra las pandillas que asolan
el país
a partir de estos momentos el municipio
de soyapango está totalmente cercado
8500 soldados y 1500 agentes han rodeado
la ciudad mientras los equipos de
extracción de la policía y el ejército
se encargan de sacar uno a uno a todos
los pandilleros que se encuentran ahí
bukele había anunciado que varias
ciudades serían o rodeadas para que la
policía pudiera inspeccionar los hogares
uno por uno y detener a los miembros de
las bandas soyapango es la primera
ciudad donde se utiliza este
procedimiento nosotros
estamos acá para garantizarle la
seguridad a la población honesta
trabajadora a finales de marzo tras la
peor masacre de la historia reciente de
este pequeño país centroamericano
atribuida a las pandillas Y en donde 87
personas murieron en tres días el
gobierno declaró el estado de emergencia
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denuncian que miles de personas han sido
detenidas a pesar de no tener ninguna
relación con las bandas informan también
de de tortura malos tratos y condiciones
inhumanas de encarcelamiento
pese a ello el
75,9% de los salvadoreños apoya el
estado de excepción y el índice de
popularidad de bukele que llevan el
poder desde 2019 ha alcanzado niveles de
récord
seguimos en la región de América Latina
porque en Colombia el gobierno de
Gustavo Petro dijo haber alcanzado un
acuerdo con el grupo eln el ejército de
liberación nacional para el retorno de
indígenas desplazados a su lugar de
origen en los departamentos occidentales
de chocó y risaralda los diálogos de paz
con la guerrilla que no ha depuesto las
armas en el país fueron suspendidos en
2019 tras un atentado a una escuela de
policía y retomados en Venezuela el
pasado 21 de noviembre bajo el nuevo
mandato de izquierda el jefe de estado
colombiano lo calificó como el primer
logro significativo en poco menos de dos
semanas de conversaciones
el primer punto de acuerdo que logramos
con el eln escasa una semana que llevan
estos diálogos es que se permite el
regreso de las poblaciones desplazadas
por esa organización de territorios
indígenas en veras a su resguardos con
garantía de no repetición y de retorno y
de Colombia vamos a acatar porque en el
mundial de fútbol hoy es un día decisivo
para cuatro selecciones estamos hablando
de Francia y Polonia por un lado e
Inglaterra y senegal por el otro que se
disputan su paso a los cuartos de final
una fase a la que Argentina y Países
Bajos ya consiguieron su cupo el sábado
hacemos conexión con uno de nuestros
enviados especiales adoja Juan pupiales
Juan los saludo muy buenos días buenas
tardes para usted con un fondo muy
bonito lo veo y pues bueno Cómo se están
preparando los equipos para estos dos
partidos tan decisivos
desde la playa de de Qatar al corazón
cultural de doja Sí aquí ya estamos
contando las horas para que se abra una
nueva fase de estos octavos de final
porque juega la campeona del mundo
Francia que se mide contra Polonia este
partido que supone el regreso de una
campeona del mundo a esta instancia 16
años después los franceses que van a
alinear a su 11 de gale al mismo equipo
que vimos contra Dinamarca con la
inclusión de Teo Hernández que dio el
susto esta semana al haberse saltado de
un entrenamiento pero ya hizo parte del
grupo al completo en la última sesión en
la previa de este partido por una por su
parte cuenta también con todos sus
efectivos disponibles para este
encuentro que supone su regreso a esta
instancia por primera vez desde
1986 Mientras tanto en el otro turno de
esta jornada de octavos de final
Inglaterra y mide contra senegal con los
ingleses Por fin ya están todos sus
efectivos que están aquí en qatará
disponibles para este partido Incluyendo
a James marison una de las sorpresas de
esta convocatoria del seleccionador
que ya por fin está disponible para este
encuentro al igual que que venía con
unas molestias en su tobillo por parte
de senegal la mala noticia es que no
contarán con uno de sus Pilares en el
centro del campo de idriza geyle el
jugador del everton que se perderá ese
encuentro por acumular dos tarjetas
amarillas Juan y otro tema del que están
muy pendientes los aficionados de todo
el mundo sobre la tabla de goleadores
Cómo se está moviendo después del gol de
ayer de Lionel Messi
con ese gol de la pulga ya hay en total
seis jugadores se acumulan tres tantos
en esta copa mundo y hay que entrar Hay
que entrar entonces en Los criterios de
desempate que ha establecido de la FIFA
que después de los goles son las
asistencias Y luego el número de minutos
gana el jugador que haya marcado esos
goles en el menor número de minutos en
los partidos disputados ahora mismo el
goleador de esta copa mundo de Qatar
2022 es el español Álvaro morata con
tres goles una asistencia en 126 minutos
con el tanto de ayer de Lionel Messi el
argentino se pone en la segunda posición
también con tres goles una asistencia y
360 minutos pero ya en cuatro partidos
el tercer lugar es para el francés
killian mbappé tres goles una asistencia
y 207 minutos hay otros tres delanteros
que también han marcado tres tantos en
esta copa mundo pero que no suman
asistencia Marcus rushford de Países
Bajos y Enner Valencia el delantero
ecuatoriano que ya no disputará más
partidos aquí después de la eliminación
de la Tricolor en esta copa mundo de
Qatar 2022 Juan pupiales Muchas gracias
Seguiremos muy atentos allá también con
Natalia Ruiz nuestros enviados
especiales y seguimos hablando de fútbol
en Brasil la estrella Edson arantes do
nacimiento mejor conocido como Pelé
sigue internado en un hospital de Sao
Paulo y se encuentra en cuidados
intensivos tras reportes no confirmados
de que había sido movido a cuidados
paliativos el deportista de 82 años
emitió un comunicado diciendo que se
sentía fuerte y con esperanza el mundo
del fútbol y los aficionados esperan su
pronta mejoría Andrés granadillo nos
tiene más detalles
buenos deseos para el rey del fútbol el
estado de salud de Pelé crea
preocupación en todas partes del planeta
tras la noticia de su hospitalización
exonerantes donamento fue internado en
el hospital israelita Albert Einstein el
pasado martes 29 para una revaluación
del tratamiento de quimioterapia para el
tumor de colon Todavía está en
tratamiento y el estado de salud se
mantiene estable futbolistas y
organizaciones del mundo esperan su
mejoría como un mbappe rivaldo Junior la
FIFA la conmebol o el equipo Santos de
Brasil en pleno mundial en doha los fans
del Astro no reconocen a otro como él
significa mucho es el mejor del mundo no
tenemos ningún otro como Pelé
tienen a Maradona en Argentina Brasil
tiene a Ronaldo como el segundo mejor
pero Pelé es el primero el más
importante
Pelé de 82 años es considerado como uno
de los mejores deportistas de todos los
tiempos el periodista Patricio de la
barra en entrevista para France 24
analizó su importancia deportiva y la
verdad es que Pelé Para mí fue uno de
los mayores iconos del fútbol mundial un
jugador que superó todas las marcas se
superó marcó más de mil goles incluso
tuvo En diversas partes del planeta Yo
lo conocí en Chile incluso cuando deja
pequeño y él ya era un gran Astro en
1958 recordemos que venció ese primer
mundial y de ahí para adelante se tornó
para mí el mejor jugador de o el mejor
atleta de la historia según el periódico
fola de Sao Paulo la quimioterapia del
Astro fue suspendida y ahora está bajo
cuidados paliativos
terminamos en Australia en donde la
policía acusó de seis delitos
relacionados con terrorismo
Cristofer prakage de 31 años sospechoso
de ser un miembro de alto perfil del
grupo estado islámico
fue arrestado en Turquía en 2016 y
extraditado hace dos días Australia que
en 2018 lo había despojado de su
ciudadanía las acusaciones en su contra
conllevan penas que van desde cinco años
hasta cadena perpetua como él las
autoridades estiman que unos 230
australianos han viajado a Irak y a
Siria para tomar las armas desde 2012
con eso terminamos nuestro informativo
los invitamos a que sigan con nosotros
[Música]